what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I talk about today's
news cultural commentary and the
audacity who had the audacity this week
so before I start don't forget to like
the video on your way in subscribe to
the channel and also sign up for our
Google form as we are going to do events
in London and the US and also guys make
sure you sign up to whale watchers wait
not whale watchers I did some of the
women were complaining so I changed it
to wife school okay but if you want to
lose weight join our program where I am
sponsoring women to lose weight that's
my charity to society my charity and
Goodwill is to pay women to work out yes
all right guys today's audacity is Adam
Adam
adam22 who who had the audacity to call
me a sexist the least sexist women woman
on the planet okay maybe I'm a little
sexist oh all right all right all right
but but
him who
gave his wife to another man
yes
so Andrew Tate who has also been on the
show decided to weigh in on this topic
so pull the footage Andrew Tate wants to
know why Adam 22 let his wife Lena do a
scene with another man this is what the
Matrix wants from you as a man go ahead
there's a guy called Adam 22. once again
I have no idea who this man is I just
saw on Twitter yesterday that he was
with a porn star who'd never done a male
scene they got married and like a week
after their marriage she did her first
male scene with some random dude and
he's on a podcast defending it did his
wife had sex with somebody else correct
why like this this is the level you
could this but this is what the Matrix
wants from you as a man they want the
woman in charge and the man below with
no backbone because if the woman's in
charge they can emotionally affect her
they can scare her you can scare a woman
easier to scare a man a man a real man's
hard to scare a woman you can make
afraid of the vaccine
right be afraid covid be scared if she's
in charge of the household I would argue
in nearly any household where the female
was dominant everyone's vaccinated I
would argue that point hard of course
maybe I'm wrong but I would argue it I
don't I don't have the statistics it's
just logic to me
so talk about women being unhappy what's
actually interesting about the female
mind once again they're going to call me
misogynist is that when you're an
emotionally LED person
you're more
prone to chaos
it takes real stoicism to lead
so why are these women unhappy because
no one's leading them no fathers no man
of no backbone no man they respect so
they're relying on society which is
promoting chaos and their own mental
state
women will say all the time ah my period
was coming up so I was crazy
like they'll say that themselves
so without any kind of hard rock of
emotional security to give her a hug and
say don't worry baby calm down it's okay
when you're not when you have no hard
rock of emotional security and you leave
her to her own devices
she's going to be to a degree chaotic
and you know who told me this a woman
said this to me a woman said this to me
a woman said most women are closer to a
mental breakdown than you possibly
believe
day by day I was like really she goes
yeah and that's that's what I love about
my husband he makes me feel happy and
secure and safe if I'm starting to have
a problem I know I go to him and he
makes me feel sick he's my rock
there's a woman said this to me a long
time ago yes
so why are women miserable because where
are they going to get their happiness
from where they're gonna their emotional
stability from it's not their job I
don't believe it's a woman's job to be
emotionally stable it's a woman's job to
do many other very important things that
men can't do more important they're
better than men at a lot of things women
are
but it's our job to be emotionally
stable women are better than us at
certain things we're better at other
things and that's why as a team we're so
powerful to sit and pretend we're all
the same the whole way through them why
do we even need each other anymore
well I don't think we do you're exactly
it and this is why we have birth rates
declining porn women who are running
around sharing one man with no intention
of having children marriage is gone like
where do we think this is going to end
and what's interesting about it ends
with the training thing right well
completely yeah that's the old time I'm
serious though is that I mean if there's
no I mean scrambling the idea of the
gender binary of sex differences like
that that is kind of the end point well
the end point is yeah men are the same
as women so it doesn't even matter
two comments and he says if he's the top
G I can be the bottom G Adam this is a
this isn't a good look I don't even know
how you'll
ever be respected by a guy again or
really women to be honest
what if he was broke if he was broke she
would be gone by now yeah she would be
gone
this is what I talk about why women
should not be in politics why women
should not be leading companies in a
management positions it's not to say
there are not exceptions to this Rule
and it's why women should not lead
households there are exceptions to this
rule not not leading households right
but
in general we have to be able to have a
conversation about Society in general
and you can just scare women like this
is what they do in the media here is a
sob story here's some sob story and
here's how you fix it by giving more
control to the government to the media
or to your community whatever it is oh
women women you need to be so sad for
the homeless people in California these
poor homeless people have just had this
horrible life and there's nothing you
can do to fix it and you need to give
them money to be homeless and that's how
in California you have them paying them
500 a month to live on the streets
the government gives them money to be
homeless
and then the women are like oh no we
gotta help the homeless people the men
understand this they're like no no no no
no you're gonna catch me
no no no no no no you will not catch me
paying for these homeless men homeless
women but this is the difference between
men and women women we're just so easy
to manipulate and propagate and just
tell us all this feminist [__] and
it's funny because I I hear these
talking points that they tell women
repeated on my show
and you'll see it like in the in the
universities and in in the feminist like
lawyers and all these feminist people
will tell us we need to be afraid of men
if you get married oh you need to be
afraid because he might leave you for a
younger woman oh if you get married you
need to make sure you have a backup plan
because otherwise the scary men and
women we're just idiots so we're just
like oh I'm so scared let me do it or
they'll say oh you know you need to be
afraid of the men
exerting control over you essay grape
the men are such violent vile creatures
when who's more violent can we think of
this who's more violent like saying that
men are more violent than women
it's a bit disingenuous because women
cannot physically be as violent as men
so how do we test this who is more
violent towards the children and the
elderly right because those are people
that can't defend themselves
guys I don't I don't mean to come across
these stats they just come to me
so we have been propagated for a hundred
years be afraid of the men be all afraid
of the men and if you are not afraid of
the men then your life is going to be
horrible
and that's my point my point is
women are easy to control get us out of
politics get us out of office and get us
out of leading marriages because do you
know what happens when we lead marriages
this treachery and debauchery and it
shows that Lena Lena did I say that
right Lena Lena well that Lena leads the
relationship because Adam said he wasn't
comfortable with it before
and now they're doing it so because and
he admitted it was her idea you know men
used to know that women just had ideas
like we would come home and like hear
something at the Women's Club whatever
and we'd go to our husbands and hear
this we had heard this crazy idea today
that men can be women and women could be
men and it used to be that you could
have the respect for your husband when
he's like oh no honey that's so cute and
sweet but maybe just make me a sandwich
because
these ideas are just crazy and then
you'd be like oh okay let me go make my
sandwich but nowadays
the men are mean that let women live in
delusion and tell us that these crazy
ideas that we come up with are sane and
valid the men that allow this delusion
in my opinion are permitting horrible
Behavior like why is a man Adam
would you allow your woman to get railed
by another man it makes no sense none
but this is the society we live in all
right next up
there is a litigation attorney that is
offering five thousand dollars to any
woman that can find her a husband
she is offering a five thousand dollar
bonus let's pull up the video king
so I'm at the spot with my boss like a
couple years ago and I've now added my
best friend her husband and a couple
other friends but I feel like I'm just
gonna open it up to the general public
because I'm good for it so the backslash
offer is if you introduce me to my
husband and I marry him I will give you
five thousand dollars I don't have to
stay married to him for long I can get
divorced in 20 years it doesn't matter
but if but if you introduce me to a man
that I walked down the aisle and get
married to I will give you 5 000 some
idioms out
of zero do you notice how she says I
don't have to be married to him for long
this is the mindset women want the
wedding more than they want the marriage
she doesn't do you hear that she doesn't
even care about being married to this
man for long all she wants is a husband
now let's let's go through her
requirements I bet they're very
deep and like I I bet you know they're
very reasonable okay at 35 being a 35
year old litigation attorney knowing
knowing that what you bring to a
marriage at 35 years old is in all
honesty nothing even if you're a hottie
which she seems like an all right
looking chick you know even if you're a
big hottie at 35 most men get married
because they want children
I would you ever get married if no kids
were involved no she the guys are
shaking their head so women know this
right the men look at you and they gotta
think could this woman raise some kids
right and if you're not bringing
children to the table
most men don't really see the point of
marriage so at 35
geriatric pregnancy starts that year so
her odds of even having kids like first
he has to get to know her so it'll be
like till 37 right most men want to get
how long you want to get in get to know
a girl before marrying her like one to
two years yeah roughly okay so now it's
37 she's pushing 40.
and that's really you're really a
depreciate and asset at that point so
you know at this point you would think
she would be desperate now like let's I
really want to ask ladies at what age
should we be desperate like why is
desperation why is it always labeled as
a bad thing sometimes desperate times
the men know this right desperate times
if they're really broke if they just
aren't looking the best they might date
a whale for a bit
you know what I mean they might marry an
ugly chick like men understand
that really in all honesty when you
think about it all men are in desperate
times when you think about it when you
think about it all men have really
adapted to the times okay because a
hundred years ago what would the man so
the man would come to the table and he
said here's your protection here's your
provisioning now a hundred years later
men still by and large outer in women
men still by and large run society and
they run all of the mechanisms that
protect women in society so women are
still getting the protection and
provisioning and before the men would
get like five kids out of the deal in
exchange they would get a virgin or at
least a chick that hadn't slept with
like I mean 85 percent of women said
they were virgins on their wedding night
let's just say some were lying still
still two out of three even if it was 50
that's better than today all right and
so they would know all right my girl
hasn't been with that many guys
and they would get
femininity a girl that wanted to stay
home raise the kids now
what do men get
a girl that has a high body count the
average woman's 170 pounds
five four
men understood you know what this is
what the Market's giving us we're
adapting to the times now women at 35
years old
still won't adapt to the market she
can't find the 511 dude that wants her
that she finds attractive so it might be
time to be desperate why is desperation
always a bad thing you know what I mean
now
she also said she's been on the dating
apps for five years now the issue you're
going to have on dating apps is that
women only swipe right on dating apps
five percent of the time so if you're
going on a date on a dating app as a
woman you're probably at a disadvantage
not because you're at a disadvantage
throughout all of dating apps but the
guy you're on a date with probably
has a ton of options and isn't going to
treat you very special all right I'm
just I'm just being honest because the
guys that we tend to swipe on have all
the women are swiping on so I don't know
if dating apps are the best you know way
but whatever so
she said so I feel like paying five
thousand dollars for a husband who's
vouched for meets my needs and is ready
for a real relationship is totally worth
it do you notice how she didn't say
anything she would bring she said he has
to meet my needs but what about you
meeting his needs but this is the thing
women will get to society has told us
chase the career be successful whatever
and she did that and she makes it to 35
years old never having once thought
about what men want
and this is why the red pill is so
important because we go through our
whole lives never having even heard what
men want
she also said can't be his second wife
lady like
you're ruling out you're 35 years old
and you're going to rule out men because
they've been married before
and then the second thing is that
5 11 or taller nowhere did you hear
anything about character did you hear
anything about values
in fact she doesn't care about political
beliefs
religious beliefs
or ethnicity so
nothing about culture nothing about
values 5 11 can never have been married
before and he has to meet my needs and
we wonder why marriage sucks today when
in the last 100 years we have had more
mate selection than ever women have had
more freedom in the last 100 years to
choose husbands and partners and you
know what we suck at it we are
absolutely terrible we don't know what
we want we just pick for looks and the
funny thing is
she says a 35 year old woman says
Hollywood heartthrobs these are these
are examples of the men she would want
Gossip Girl star Chuck Bass Oscar
winning Matthew McConaughey
so you tell me is this reasonable
is that do you think this is a
reasonable list you know I I appreciate
that she's bringing money to the table
but it's funny how women it's like our
solution is to pay people to do work for
us instead of putting in the work to
becoming better wives and mothers
instead of learning skills that would
give us the outcome we want it's funny
because they'll call men in cells in the
red pill right they'll see all these red
pill men or just in cells they can't get
women a lot of men will agree and say
you know what I can't get women I'm
broken I'm fat
and they'll take a path towards
Improvement but where are all the real
women's improvement classes genuinely I
don't see them I see women going to some
feminist therapist that makes us worse
okay I I see us going to some feminist
therapists that just makes us worse
people
going to the gym a bit posting some
selfies on Instagram learning how to do
your makeup a little better and then
slap in a selfie on Instagram saying
I've healed oh and taking a trip to
Aruba
yes I forgot about the trip to Aruba
where they just learned to be the best
version of ourselves a wife a mother and
yeah that that's what I see but the men
I at least see improving
you know there's many testimonials from
guys like fresh and fit and all these
other self-improvement guys where they
get in better shape
they make more money how many have you
seen a self-improvement like women
losing weight in cookbooks and like
going back to more traditional values
and the funny thing is men are much more
traditional than women nowadays yet the
conservatives and the Trad cons will say
oh well the men just need to be better
they need to be better when it's like
all right men pay 80 percent of the
taxes men run the entire infrastructure
of society which one out of two men is
in an industry that runs the
infrastructure so protection and
provisioning from a societal standpoint
men are doing more
um the women are the ones that aren't
holding a bar under the bargain are
we're having 1.4 children or 1.2 roughly
we're not even having an average of two
kids it's like all right so the men pay
all the taxes they run the entire
infrastructure of society they have made
systems that protect us like the police
the military and the judicial system
that'll also protect us and all they
want in return is some kids and we can't
even do that is the crazy thing
and they want to get mad at me for
pointing things out and saying you know
what Trad cons I don't think women and
men are offering equal value to society
I don't think women are helping run
Society I think nowadays we have less
value and the funny thing is the oh the
funny thing is
these ladies will come in and say I am
tradcon but if you went to college
you cannot be you can't be traditional
because college is a feminist
Institution for Women yes if you look at
the birth rate and the rate of women
having children
it's in verse
they're trying to program us to not have
this is the crazy thing now my point is
this
why do we have a society that is always
focused on the men and the men need to
be better but never the women and if
anyone says anything about the women
they get attacked mercilessly
maybe I'm crazy though I don't know
maybe I just don't know what I'm talking
about I'm just grifting making some
things up I I'm just I'm just
reiterating what I see
so the next topic what's next we have
another woman that just had the audacity
and I want to show you guys this is the
level of advice so in my generation
what advice did I hear growing up did I
ever hear the teachers at school that
just are doing such a good job
everyone's saying oh thank God we have
these teachers just helping out they're
just doing such a great job did they
ever ask me if I wanted to be a wife and
a mother no they said what do you want
to be when you grow up that is the
question they ask young women and men
but women you know you know it's a
different connotation this is the level
of advice of the wives and mothers we
have to look up to now I'd like to draw
your attention to a poll
that I did on Twitter
as the average wife a good wife and
mother
63 percent said no
now I have a sneaky suspicion that the
37 that said yes is a lot of women okay
now I'm not you know but so this is
across the board men and women I had 5
000 people vote in this poll
now is
are men happy with the quality of wives
today do you guys think
do you think this is a good product
we're offering so then I always hear go
to the church it's just it's just the
women that you have on your show Pearl's
just making [__] up as usual I said is
the average Christian woman submissive
to her husband you know what's funny I
got no more no's on this than the first
question 70 said no
so this is
asking the General Public
they're telling me
the quality of wives is bad across the
board it's bad in the church it's bad in
the market because more people think
we're bad than good okay so that's not
just picking random women that this is
just asking the market
now let's let's go to this great advice
that we get let's let's pull it up I
love when you look healthy and Youthful
and listen I don't really give a [__]
what men love and nor should you because
reminder they will [__] a corpse okay so
but the one thing I do know that men
hate okay uh it's not really if you're
old or wrinkly uh they don't even hate
if you're out of shape they don't even
really hate if you're a [__] they don't
even really hate if you're mean they
don't hate if you're fat they don't hate
if you're a single mom they don't even
hate if you're missing teeth they don't
even hate any of that they will [__] all
of that you know what they won't [__]
though
they will not [__] confident [__]
let me tell you
that is the number one and only boner
killer
for men
so ladies
if you would like men to leave you alone
for the rest of your life
don't do any of the things that this
young lady suggests because men will not
men will annoy you forever
um and you don't even have to worry like
they'll still hit on you if you're old
they'll still hit on you if you're
wrinkly and unattractive but if you're
confident
[__]
they don't want nothing to do with you
so ladies take it from me cause men
[__] hate my guts
because I am confident
so if you just so you just that in case
you wanted to know because nobody cares
what men want okay
do men do men hate your guts because
you're confident or because you have a
tattoo sleeve I mean I'm just I'm just
asking questions okay okay do men hate
your guts because you got these like
Raptor claws nails
or do they hate your confidence do men
hate your guts because you're not a nice
person
or is it the confidence now this is the
level of women we have to learn from and
the crazy thing is
you see women with tattoo sleeves in
churches and outside of churches Raptor
claws in churches and outside of
churches you see wives that will not
submit to their husbands in churches and
outside of churches I hear women say
they cannot obey their husband that
that's too far how is that too far when
they do everything in society and we're
willing to obey our boss we're willing
to obey the police but we can't obey our
husbands
really and this isn't to say that every
woman's gonna be a perfect wife a
perfect mother we know we know nobody's
perfect
but if we cannot agree on an Ideal
and we have women confusing us about the
ideal she just said men don't care if
you're out of shape wrong
men don't care if you're a single mother
if you're old if you're wrinkly are men
lining up to date 70 year old chicks
can we just call it can we just call us
bay to Spade I I'm just so tired of the
delusion I don't I'm not even I don't my
if you're a single mother you're living
your life whatever but what I hate is
delusion where I have to look at women
living in delusion and I can't comment
on it
I can't say that's delusional it's
delusional to think you have the same
level of attention with a kid or without
a kid it's delusional to say you have
the same level of attention when you're
old or if you're young if you're 25 or
35 when your eggs are gone I am tired of
this delusion I'm so tired
now now she was right about one thing
men will screw anything that is true if
a guy has a couple shots you know what I
mean it's just been a while for him men
will they will screw anything
but women think that means something
guys it doesn't mean anything
it literally means nothing
I mean guys have you ever screwed a
chick that you're embarrassed about
oh they're not they're they're laughing
why are you laughing guys why
I
I mean call me crazy but I don't think
that's the same thing as a ring I don't
and I'm finding out that 63 percent of
men are walking away from relationships
and it's funny because whenever I hear
the Trad cons talk they just blame it on
the men they're like well they're broke
losers anyway that's why they're walking
away and it's so funny because I'm like
it couldn't be the quality of the women
and I look at the stats I'm like how you
know I used to I used to kind of get
upset when I would hear like that the
the the
red pill guys be like oh the women are
so bad until I started to look at
history and I'm like historically
for marriage the men would get a young
beautiful virgin and now they get and
this is just the average bride they're
like oh Pearl you're just bringing up
exceptions to the rule this is according
to the numbers this is the average bride
and Rising overweight
has slept with multiple men
and there's a one out of three chance
she's had an abortion or an STD I mean
can we say this is good and this isn't
to completely [__] on women like to be
fair
devil's advocate here
from a young age we have been told chase
the career the bag that is the most
important thing so we're not necessarily
saying it is only women's fault
but it's a lot our fault
because it is the choices that we made
and that's the funny thing it's like
what does that say about women
if we as a group as a group The more
Choice we've had the more we've chosen
to be [__]
now I'm not even saying this to be mean
but I'm just like looking at the numbers
I'm like okay a hundred years ago
1920s was when women started to get
their own Apartments before 1920s women
went from their dad's house
to their husband's house there was no in
between the 1920s The Roaring Twenties
happened the women started cutting their
hair putting on their little Jiggy
dresses going down the town and
shimmying right and I was I was
literally thinking about this I'm like
so we got more choice they said women
here you go choice and what did women
choose to do
be [__] now I'm not even saying this
to be mean because historically 95 of
women would be [__] because they're
not virgins on their wedding day 95 of
women would not qualify for marriage
okay you know and I'm not saying this to
be mean I'm just looking at the numbers
so I'm thinking
do women naturally make good decisions
and I was I was literally thinking about
this too women can be great wives and
mothers but I realize that the only way
we can be great at things is under the
authority of a man because when we do
things on our own we suck like we
literally suck I literally think that if
I didn't have my dad helping me with
like you know the YouTube channel I
talked to some men whatever I have the
men running the cameras I'm a woman I
would just like you know flop and just
like chill out but but luckily women can
only be great under men yes we are the
men are the superior beings
and they'll call me a pick me for this
but every time I look at the numbers I'm
like I can't think of one thing that
women are good at by ourselves we can't
even raise kids by ourselves we suck
like I I look at the numbers 80 of
prisoners are from single mother homes
single father homes fare very single
similar they're very similar to two
parent homes so then I'm like well maybe
we're better at the infants we're better
at raising the infants no we're more
likely to kill infants than men I'm like
well so I realized I'm like women can be
great but women can only be great under
the authority of men women want to be
able to have these boss chick jobs in HR
just policing everybody they wouldn't
get to be the queen of HR if they didn't
have companies to go be the HR police
then I mean sorry guys we have real jobs
we totally do
I just can't really think of any I'm
gonna be honest not that we really
dominate in I found out the other day
that two women can't teach as well as
one man
how sad is that for us as a species so
you know it's not to say we suck at
everything
because we don't but men are better at
it men are the superior beings
sorry feminists I don't know what to
tell you the point of this is we have
lived in such delusion
that we have a 35 year old corporate
lawyer who probably will not reproduce
feeling like she deserves Leonardo
DiCaprio because we have been told since
childhood that we are equal to men and
we are not they are superior thank you
the next story is now you would think
because as women we are no longer
traditional sorry ladies if you were not
married before 25 I include myself in
this all right women that are
traditional means they prioritize a
family before career if you are not
married before 25 that means you do that
means you prioritize something else
above family me personally it was
volleyball sorry guys you know you can't
it is what it is but you would think
right because women are coming to the
table we're just not as traditional as
we used to be we would give the men a
little bit of leeway right I mean how
can you expect a perfectly traditional
outcome without being a perfectly
traditional woman that's right King
right yeah I mean you would think we
give so much leeway to the men like okay
it's all right if you don't pay all the
time okay you know you don't have to be
a perfectly masculine leader like you
think we would offer some Grace because
the men are offering us a ton of Grace
so you would think we would say all
right let's offer the men some Grace now
this woman talks about what she expects
from a man when he meets her and her
friends I'm sure it's going to be
reasonable when a guy meets your friends
for the first time should he pay for all
your friends even if there's like four
of them one two three yes
wow this is I I'm so sorry to the guys
this is crazy this is delusion so she's
saying
not only does he need to traditionally
Court you
but he needs to traditionally Court your
friends
now let's go back can I can I see the
picture of them one more time just the
picture do these look like traditional
women that deserve traditional outcomes
so we got a potentially spray tan hoop
earrings
um
you know dyed hair
t-shirts now now go back now this isn't
this isn't to hate on them just because
you're modern it doesn't mean bad person
okay so a lot of times women will get
triggered and they're like well but but
but
I didn't say bad person
but you would think if you're asking for
I want the traditional outcome
you would have traditional skills
and a traditional at least you would
think okay the funniest thing you would
think at least they would have a
traditional mindset like okay
you're not gonna get the virgin anymore
okay you know I'm a bit older but you
would think they would say I will obey
my husband
and mean it
no no no
no I mean maybe they do say that I just
don't I mean maybe did you get that vibe
that they would obey no I mean I I don't
know maybe maybe but this is the level
and then it's so funny because all the
Trad cons will come in and say well
men just be better
make more money for the women be better
and then the men are like well what am I
getting out of this 1.2 kids have ran
through ho and will I at least get youth
oh no not even that anymore I
and that's why a lot of guys are walking
away I'm not trying to be mean
a lot of times women we've been misled
but I'm just calling it like I see it
and you would think the women at least
would meet the men halfway and say okay
I can compromise on some of the
traditional outcomes
no
nothing we compromise on nothing
apparently
I'd like to say that I'm getting
involved in charity work so I've
sponsored a fat chick in London and I'm
looking to sponsor one more where I have
paid for her personal training and
nutrition
out of the kindness of my heart and I've
also started a group for women that want
to lose weight called wife school
because it starts with looks for men and
where I myself also am going to be
trying to get in better shape and being
a healthier version of myself
um and there's a three thousand dollar
prize all funded by me
I mean you could call me a full uh what
do they call them the philanthropists
the the the I really think I'm doing
good more good to society than anything
imagine we could I I should start a golf
on me
that people can donate to to pay women
to get on the treadmill
uh
philanthropist I swear to God I swear
okay but
now let's look at is obesity celebrated
in society
is obesity promoted or is it shamed
let's see let's show show the footage
[Music]
forever
all right she's still human isn't she
entitled to her feelings we're all
beautiful in our own way I knew this
would be here is she dancing or so did
someone bump into her five minutes ago
and she still won
that's funny y'all in the comments are
actually sick if you don't like it just
scroll instead of putting this innocent
girl who's done nothing but have fun
she's representing the planets
I get it's funny because the men are
making fun of her put that same energy
into the gym yes the tides are turning
people okay now let's let's go back it's
funny because the men are making fun of
her and the women are saying you guys
are just being mean you're so mean oh
you big mean mean mean mean mean people
now my question is this
what is Kinder because you know if
someone makes fun of you you might fix
it but if you allow people to live in
delusion
if you allow people to live in delusion
then they spend the rest of their life
thinking that something is okay and it
is not okay to be that fat why I I think
crop tops for fat people should be
banned
band I want to ban so many things on top
of divorce on top of birth control I
would only let skinny people wear crop
tops
ban it we should ban fat clothes too you
gotta work and get in the treadmill
look at guys because
why do we all have to look at your fat
you know we're kind of borderline
repulsed by giant giant blubber okay we
don't like seeing it can we stop
pretending we want to see this stuff no
we don't put the blubber away when I was
a kid my mother always told me
that you have to earn a bikini body
now I don't say you need to be perfect
but can we agree that 300 pounds
is too much like I didn't say you have
to put away the stretch marks or the
scars you know if you've had a surgery
or something but can we agree that we
don't want to see
300 250 pound women at the beach on the
street just being so fat where it's like
if you're at a concert or or an event
and you're just this fat maybe it's time
to go into the treadmill instead
maybe it's time and they're like well
she's just a living and existing well
maybe could she exist in the gym
and live in the gym
I
and you know what I will never [__] on
someone who is trying
who is trying but what I will [__] on is
US celebrating and being confident about
obesity you cannot be confidently obese
your cholesterol says otherwise
your cholesterol is not confident it is
not your cholesterol your sugar whatever
I'm not a science person but all of your
body organs are screaming please please
please and we're gonna say be confident
to an early death to a lower standard of
living to everybody having to deal with
your problems when that woman does
anything
it turns into a problem for someone else
her being obese who's got to take care
of her any boyfriend or family that she
has
her being obese who has to look at her
the general public her being obese what
what is she encouraging younger people
to be obese because we're saying this is
beautiful this is okay
if she goes to the doctor
even if even if she dies everyone's got
to pick her up you know and I'm not
wishing that so don't don't don't don't
don't [__] me reaction channels but but
I'm saying no matter what she does it is
going to be a problem for someone else
so maybe we should fix the problem look
it guys I'm gonna start a GoFundMe to
pay women to stop being fat yes yes call
it God's work call it let me find the
charity that you would really want to
donate to
God's work I don't know okay but let me
let me know in the comments guys what
you think don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell I'll talk to you guys next time